이끈 정상까지 직접 처리하는 Agentinitiary Commerce가 있고
다음으로는 예산 한도 한에서
Agent가 직접 지갑에 설명하는 얼어낮면서 on-chain 세럼 노트가 있습니다.
그 다음에는 Agent끼리 협상하고
주문하는 Multi-Agent Commerce가 있고
다음으로는 자격을 판정해
on-chain으로 증명하고
데뷤으로 지급하는 multiple distribution 있습니다.
이 4가지는 반드시 골라야 하는 트랙이 아니라
시작점 가이드라는 것이기 때문에
조합을 하셔도 되고
완전히 새로운 방향도 환영합니다.
일정은 핵심 날짜만 잡으시면 되고요.
저희가 모집은 지난주 금요일부터 시작했고
21일은 키고프입니다.
빌드미크는 지난주 금요일부터
하룰 3일까지 진행이 되고 있고요.
저희 해코톤 디스코드 들어가 보시면
저희 솔라나 파운데이션의
페이다시엘 개발자님도 계시고
그리고 그룹을 매니저님,
솔라나 재단 매니저님 모두 계시고
소필라스 리서처 그런 것도
제공받을 수 있습니다.
저희 최종 제출 바감은
8월 3일, 월요일 밤 11시 59분
한국 시간입니다.
8월 7일에는 파이널리스트 약 10팀을 발표하고
8월 10일부터 20일까지
파이널리스트 조명 집중 멘토링이 이어집니다.
그리고 8월 20일 금요일
구글스타트 캠퍼스에서
오프라인 데모데이로 마무리되는 일정이라고 보시면 됩니다.
제출물에는 크게 3가지입니다.
포롱트 속에서 기트북 데모 영상입니다.
타겟이나 문제, 스윙몬드, 아키텍처를 만든
프로덕트 속에서 100을 제출해 주시면 되고요.
PTT도 상관없고
슬라이브도 상관없고 PDF도 상관없습니다.
이 4가지 요소만 잘 적어주시면 감사 드리고요.
다음으로는 재형 가능한 코드, 리듬이가 있는 기트북
주소 제출해 주시면 감사 드리고
다음으로는 이 AI 에이전트 결제가
전 과정이 시연이 되고 있는지
데모 영상 주시면 감사하겠습니다.
여기에 라이브, 배포, URA까지 함께 내시면
이제 보너스 가상점이 있습니다.
단 하나 기억해 주셔야 되는 게
목업은 심사와 대상에서 제외가 됩니다.
아무래도 저희가 데모데이 다엘에
주관석뿐만 아니라 금융권 파트너 사업분들도 오시기 때문에
결제가 실제로 동작하는
끝까지 생각을 하시고 만들어주시면 감사 드리겠습니다.
심사는 4가지 추구로 봅니다.
혁신성과 UX
실제로 상업성이 가능한지 영워를 제일 만져볼 것 같고
그 다음은 재미나이를 비롯한 AI 활용도
그리고 인투라, U.S.D.C, 온설라나
그리고 솔라나 페이다 쉘 이런 걸 보고
마지막은 실행 로고와 일역 기반의
실제 부동 로고입니다.
저희는 화면이 아니라 진짜 트렌듀션을 보일 예정입니다.
그러면 이번 해코톤의 가장 큰 장점을
하나씩 설명을 드리고자 합니다.
저희는 해코톤 시작부터 글로벌 진출까지
end to end로 지원한다는 점인데요.
우선은 8월 3일까지의 빌드위크 때는
구글 클라우드 300트레딧과
솔라나 재단의 페이다 쉘 당당자님의 면역토리
그리고 탑티어 블록체인 리서치공의
코펠러스 리서치를 제공해 드릴 예정입니다.
그래서 각각을 참고하셔서
이 해코톤의 기초를 다지시면
되게 좋을 것 같습니다.
그 다음으로는 이제 저희가 최종 10팀을 선정할 예정인데
이 10팀 한정하에 이제
신안카드, 더즌, KD26, SKG,
파인이셜, KSN에든
금융권 실무장분들의 밀착 멘토링을
받으실 수 있습니다.
이제 아이디어가 실제 이 시장에 부합한
이제 도입 가능한 프로덕트까지 이어지는 경험을 받으실 수 있고요.
그리고 마지막으로는 솔라나 재단
슈퍼팀 코리아의 통속 빌딩 지원을
탄탄하게 해드리는 예정입니다.
저희가 상금, 저희 해코톤
홈페이지를 보시면 이렇게 적혀있어요.
솔라나 재단의 그런치 프로그램을 통해 직접 지급되고
상금의 절반은 솔라나 글로벌 해코톤 참여 시 지급됩니다.
이 말인 즉슨
이제 저희가 이 해코톤을 만약에 수상하지 않아도
이 프로덕트를 가지고 이후에 이제
솔라나 슈퍼팀 코리아에서 진행하는 스탄톤 빌딩지
그리고 솔라나 재단에서 문영하는 글로벌 해코톤까지
계속 기회가 있기 때문에
이 기회들을 놓치지 않았으면 좋겠습니다.
그래서 이제 하나 이제
블록진 업계에 대해서 잘 모르시는 분들도 위해서
자세히 설명을 드리자면
스타트업 빌딩은 솔라나 선택에서
프로덕트 설계 개발 출시를 목표로 하는
이제 빌더를 위한 집중 지원 프로그램입니다.
그래서 이 이후 이제 한국 목표 해코톤과
솔라나 공식 해코톤까지
좋은 성과를 내고
성공적인 프로젝트를
성장할 수 있는 탄탄한 발판을 다져드리는데요.
해코톤 준비 전략부터 피칭 훈련
산업 전문가 멘토링까지
이제 성공적인 프로젝트 런칭에
필요한 모든 과정을 경험하실 수 있습니다.
그 다음에 솔라나 재단 공식 후원하는
이제 가장 큰 글로벌 해코톤인데요.
이 수상가는 인터뷰를 걸쳐서
콜로세운 맥설레이터 프로그램을
참여할 수 있는 기회를 얻게 되는데
뭐 초기 자본투자 파티어 창업가
그 합류 중 1대1 멘토링을 받으실 수 있습니다.
그래서 이 구글 솔라나 해코톤을 통해서
만들어진 프로젝트를 이렇게
뭐 유니콘 스타트까지 성장할 수 있는 영향을
가질 수 있는 이제
엔드 투 엔드 서비스를 제공해드리니
이제 꼭 열심히 참여를 해주셨으면
감사드리겠습니다.
저희 상금 풀 같은 경우는 아까 말씀드렸듯이
총 5000달러 1등은 3000달러 2등은 1500
3등은 500달러 입니다.
솔라나 파운데이션의 그란치를 통해서 직접 제공하고
아까 금액의 절반은
솔라나 글로벌 해코톤을 직접
진출을 해야지 받으실 수 있습니다.
참가자 극은 누구나 열려 있습니다.
블록체인 경험이 없어도 참여가 가능하고
실제로 이제
실제로 블록체인 경험 없이도
이 해코톤을 통해서
이제 블록체인 수상을 한 경험도
있는 사람들도 많기 때문에
이번 기회에 블록체인 입문하신다고 생각하고
접근을 해보시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
그래서 뭐 AR 빌더, 블록체인 빌더
뭐 기알빵 기간 기업소속 빌더
뭐 연령 제공
연령 제안도 딱히 없습니다.
그리고 개인 1인 참여도 가능하고요.
이제 뭐 만약에 팀 결성 시 최대 4년까지
팀으로 참여 가능합니다.
자유로운 팀 빌딩 지원 같은 경우는
저희 해코톤 디스코트 들어가시며
이제 자유로운 팀 빌딩 구성하셔서
해주셔도 됩니다.
이제 저희가 아무래도 이 해코톤을 진출하기 위해서는
구글 클라운드 크래딧을 사용하셔야 되는데
이 크래딧 가이드도 꼭 말씀드리고 싶습니다.
우선은 첫 번째 참가에는
개인 진일 계정이 필수입니다.
학교나 해산 워크 스테이스 계정은
크래딧 정책삭 제한될 수 있습니다.
둘째 개인 진일 가입시 받는 300 크래딧은
재미나이 API 사용류와 별개 시스템이라
재미나이 API는 쓸 수 없습니다.
근데 이제 재미나이 API 자체의 무료 티오가 있기 때문에
이거를 사용하시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
그래서 이 부분 헷갈리시는 분들이 많아서
꼭 기억을 해주셨으면 좋겠습니다.
그래서 이제 정리하자면
에이전티 커머스 프로덕트를 만들어서
8월 3일까지 제출을 하시고
8월 21일에 데모되어 있는
실제로 에이전트 결제를 라이브로 보여주시면 됩니다.
저희가 디스코드랑 공식 사이트 링크는
이제 이렇게 QR코드로 안내드렸고
채팅방에서도 링크를 보내드리도록 하겠습니다.
저희가 지금 연달아서 3명의 연사분이 있기 때문에
지금 QR를 받지 않고
궁금한 신정이 있으면 채소로 말하시거나
그러면 저희가 답글로 달아드리도록 하겠습니다.
그럼 이제 본격적으로
오늘의 첫 패션으로 넘어가 보도록 하겠습니다.
이제 첫 시장은 시장을 읽는 눈입니다.
국내 대표 이제 글로벌
블록체 리서치 펌 코필러스의
유준영 리서치 님이
에이전티 커머스를 둘러싼
시장의 흐름과 X40이
MPP 기반의 에이전트 결제의 지용도를 짚어주시는데
지금 왜 시장이 에이전티 커머스에 주목하고 있는지
보실 수 있을 것 같습니다.
그럼 유준영 리서치 님 오시겠습니다.
아 혹시 목소리 들리시나요?
네 잘 들립니다.
그러면 시작하도록 하겠습니다.
이번 시간 기술 스텍 조금보다는
어떤 식으로 에이전티 커머스가 흘러가고
그 과정에서 X40 MPP가 어떤 위치를 가지고 있는지
그리고 추가적으로 제가 제 소개에 적지는 않았는데
약간 해커톤을 참가할 때 어떤 관점으로 보면 좋을지
약간 개인적인 관점을 섞어서
한번 발표를 진행해 보겠습니다.
일단 간략하게
일단 간략하게 제 소개를 하자면
현재 포필러스에서 리서처로 일하고 있는
유준영이라고 하고 MPP X401을
뒤로 타는 많은 에이전티 커머스크를 썼으면
실제 금융지관에서도 몇 번 이용이 됐었고
그다음에 특히 8월에 리눅스의 수치한 오픈소스 서멘에서
X40에 관련해서 강연을 할 예정입니다.
이에 맞춰서 X40에 관련된
딥타이브한 보고서 또 발견 예정이
이미 많은 관심 가져올 수는 좋겠습니다.
일단 먼저 시작하기 앞서 가지고
저희가 이걸 정리해야 됩니다.
큰일이 에이전티 댕댕댕이라고 얘기할 때
에이전티 커머스, 에이전티 페이먼트,
헤드리스 러스천트 엔트 포인트
등등이 다양한 얘기하고 주었는데
저희가 이거에 대해서 약간 딱 범위를 전해야되면
일단 먼저 에이전티 커머스는
저희가 흔히 생각하는
무언가를 구매하고는 할 때 약간 이 커머스 그런 거 있죠.
그런 것을 그런 커머스 시장을
공략한다고 생각하시면 됩니다.
그래서 이제 구매 주체가 사람이 아니라
사람을 대리하는 AI 에이전티 상관이고
에이전티 페이먼트는 그냥
에이전트가 페이먼트를 하는 모든 과정
그리고 마찬가지로 헤드리스 러천트 엔트 포인트는
약간 생소하실 수도 있는데
최근에 약간 미국을 비롯한 다양한 블록징 업계에서
이 헤드리스 머천트 엔트 포인트 시장을
이제 중화하고 있습니다.
간단히 이야기하면 UI 레이어
그러니까 인간을 위해 설계된 모든 레이어를 제거하고
API 엔트 포인트 자체가 이제 판매
적점이 되는 머천트 형태를 제공하는 것이
이 헤드리스 머천트 엔트 포인트입니다.
그래서 에이전티 커머스 지형도를 한번 그려보자면
이렇게 수많은 다양한 백테크 기업들과
블록체인 회사들이
이거 에이전티 커머스에 빠르게 녹여들고 있습니다.
대표적으로 이제 저희가 함께 할
구분 클라우드와 솔라를 비롯해서
서클베이스 클라우드 플레이어
그리고 비자 마스터카로 오픈해야 AWS
그리고 이제 블록체인 쪽으로 넘어가면
알캐미, 벤커, 메리치, 시스템, 퍼리티오스,
프로토콜드는 수많은 이제 프로젝트들이
이 에이전티 커머스에 중화하고 있습니다.
그러면 이제 저희가
이번 헤드커톤에 어떤 부분에
집중해야 되나 봤을 때
일단 에이전티 커머스를
다섯 가지 레이어드로 분리해보겠습니다.
먼저 첫 번째
가장 윈 레벨에 있는 것은 이제
에이전트 상원형인데
A2A 이것도 제가 이게
두글 클라우드가 만들었다가
최근에 이제 리든스 파운데이션이
이관된 것을 알고 있는데
흔히 이제 저희가 에이전트가
툴들을 쉽게 부르기 위해서
한 공통뿜에서 MCP라고 하는 것처럼
이제 에이전트끼리 스터드 소통할 때
이제 공통대 뿜에서 자유롭게
소통하는 것을 A2A라고 합니다.
이게 왜 그러냐면
여러분 아시겠지만 각자 에이전트를 만드는
이제 에이전트 프레이머크가
랭 체인부터 시작해서
쉽게 수백기가 있습니다.
근데 그것들은 일일이
다 SDK처럼 묶어가지고
이제 소통 방식을 만들기 힘들거든요.
그래서 이런 게 이제 A2A고
다음에 상거래 상원형 표전인
이제 저희가 이번에 구글클라우드 함께 하기 때문에
구글클라우드 위주로 한번 해 보겠습니다.
구글클라우드와 만들 이제 UCP
그리고 AP2
그리고 밑에 있는 결제 정살내에서
MPPX40이가 있습니다.
그래서 이번 헥거톤을 위해서는
아무래도 구글클라우드나
솔랑아 관련증 것을
중점을 보는 게 좋겠죠.
그래서 여러분들이
참고하기 딱 좋고
이 영화에 딱 좋은 것을 이렇게
다섯 가지 프로듀그를
생각하시면 되겠죠.
그래서 일단 결제 레일부터 보겠습니다.
X40와 MPP
X40에 그래도 어느 정도 들어보신 분들이 있을 거고
MPP는 약간 스트라이비나
약간 케이먼트에 관련되어서
어느 정도 조금 관심이 있으신 분들 아실 거고
그다음에 처음 들으신 분들도 계실 겁니다.
일단 먼저 이것을 왜 소개하냐면
이제 저희가 이제
뒤에 이제 체리님의 소개할 수
이제 pay.sh에서는
MPP와 X40 두 개 다 동시에 지원합니다.
그러기 때문에 어느 정도 차이점을
아시면 좋겠다는 생각하여
약간 발표를 진행하게 되었습니다.
이게 기본적인 원리고
사실 이게 X40의 지형도 있는데
MPP와 X40을 소개하는데
X40의 지형도 한 이유는
살살 MPP가 X40를 기반으로
약간 특정 기능만
약간 좀 조작한
그런 프로듀그를 생각하시면 됩니다.
그래서 이렇게 쭉 이어지는데
사실 이제 이게
시간도 한정되어 있다 보니까
뭐 쭉 설명하기에는 좀 그렇고
간단히 이제 의리만 말씀드리면
여러분이 이제
고객이고
여러분이 한 명이
이제 서비스 제공자가 생각합시다.
그러면 그 서비스 제공자가 있는데
갑자기 한 클라이터를 다가와서
어 나 이거
Circle stablecoin으로 결제하고 싶어
뭐 SIP USDC로 결제하고 싶어
라고 물었다고 합니다.
근데 여기서
만약에 서비스 제공자가
블록체인 거래를
이제 릴레이어나 이런 걸 통해 가지고
처리할 수 없는 환경이라는 거 어떻게 해야 될까요?
이 과정에서
이제 그 거래를 대신
대신 완료시키고
그 대신 수술을 받아가는 게
여기 여기 있는
Fusilitator입니다.
그래서 이 Fusilitator가
결론적으로 거래를 이제
주간에서 완료해 주고
서버는 블록체인 스텍을 잘 몰라도
Fusilitator 하나만으로
이제 편하게
이제 stablecoin이든
뭐 특정 코인 거래든 해 가지고
이 결제를 완료할 수 있는 게
사실 이런 머신페이먼스 프로듀컬
혹은 이제 X40에
주된 포인트가 생각하시면 됩니다.
그래서 이걸 보시면
제가 대략적으로 지형도 그려 봤는데
오른쪽에 있는 거는 지금
X40이 커뮤니티 주도고
왼쪽에는 MPP는 이제 기업주도 입니다.
MPP는 이제
템포 네트 것, 스트라이프
그다음에 오픈에 함께 하고 있고
X45에는 이제
뭐 베이스와 클라우드 플레이어가
이제 핵심 멤버였는데
이제 올해 4월 2일에
리눅스 파운데이션 인간이 되었죠.
그래서 솔라는 사실 X40이
이제 핵심 멤버기도 하고
MPP 쪽에서 지원이 합니다.
근데 사실 이렇다고 볼 수가 없는 게
결론적으로 파이가 작기 때문에
모든 프로듀컬, 모든 프로젝트
모든 객체들이 결론적으로
하나씩 이제 손을 맞잡아 가면서
파이를 넓혀 가고자 하는 게
현재 흐름이기 때문에
딱히 뭐 어떤 스텍에
약간 종속되지 않아도 되긴 합니다.
그래서 뭐
이거는 이제 X40이와 이제
MPP의 대략 전에 차이인데
사실 여기서 말씀드리자면
X40이 또 MPP식의
세션 결제를 지원할 수 있습니다.
예를 들어서
제가 뭐
예를 들어서 뭐 오픈 AI의
이제 7GPT의 API를
뭐 10번 거래하고 싶다고 하면
X45에는 10번 리퀘스트를 해야 되는데
MPP는 뭐 세션을 열어가지고
이 세션 안에서 10번에 거래를
한 번에 처리할 수 있다
뭐 이런 건데
이게 X40이의 큰 틀이 결론적으로 MPP 안에 있기 때문에
결론적으로 뭐 이런 차이가 있다라고
가볍게 넘어가시면 됩니다.
그리고 이것은 이제
봤을 때 MPP는 결론적으로
스트라이비랑 템포가 함께하는
약간 기업과 중심
약간 기업 중심의 프로토콜에 생각하시면 되고
X45 있는 리눅스 재단의
이제 이관되었기 때문에
커뮤니티 중심
오픈스 중심의 이제
프로토코이라고 생각하시면 됩니다.
그래서 뭐 제가 뭐
뭐 30도 1시간 동안
설명될 수 없으니까
자세한 스펙은
X40이나 MPP 닥스를 첨부하시면 됩니다.
요즘 뭐 클러드나 CPT 있으니까
확실하고 드럽지 않습니다.
그래서 뭐 많이 찾아보시고
혹시라도 약간 좀 개념에 헷갈리시다 하시면
모티스코드나 텔레벨으로 질문 주시면
제가 손실에 답변드리겠습니다.
그리고 이제 다음은
이제 그 결제 레일 위에 있는
이제 구글 클러드의 A28, AP2, 그리고 UCP입니다.
A28는 앞서 말씀드리다시피
MCP가 결론적으로
툴드를 쉽게 약간
끌어오르기에 맞는
통신 프로토콜인 것처럼
A28는
에이전트 간의 통신 프로토콜에서 사용하시면 됩니다.
그래서 다른 에이전트의 능력 발견하고
뭐 테스크 위임,
PUC 정보 공유가 가능한데
그러면 저 구분의 통합스텍인
A28, AP2, UCP로 갑니다.
그래서 결론적으로 A28와 MCP는
경쟁이 아닌 상황과 함께인데
에이전트끼리 수통하는 건 A28
에이전트가 특정 툴
API나 이제 뭐
어플리케이션을
호출할 때는 MCP를 사용하신다고 생각하시면 됩니다.
그리고 AP2는
구글이 제안하는
맨데이트 기반의 에이전트 결제 프로토콜인데
아마 뭐 구글 클라우드 공유
아마 자세하게 설명 드릴 수도 있겠지만
간단히 설명 드리자면
에이전트가 특정에
머스텐트 이쿠스템이나
페이먼트 이쿠스템 구매할 때
이게 결론적으로
어떤 결정과 실내받고
이런 거를 헷갈리거든요.
그래서 그거를
맨데이시라는 위임장 기반에
이제 오픈, 클로스트,
페이먼트 맨데이서
기반으로 해서 처리하는 게
이제 AP2인데 이것도
자세히 아마 찾아보시면
아마 쉽게 이해가 되실 겁니다.
그리고 A28와 AP2를 묶어 가지고
나온 게 UCP고요.
결론적으로 유니버스 커버스 프로토콜이라 해가지고
이 모든 쇼핑 레이어, 커버스 레이어나
한 번에 통합해서 만든 게 UCP입니다.
그러면 이제 여기서 질문이 있을 수가 있죠.
이것이 AP2, A28, UCP가
이제 블록체인 기반에
이제 에이전트 페이먼트 프로토콜가
어떤 관계가 있냐.
AP2에서
머스텐트 이쿠스템이나
페이먼트 이쿠스템에서 결제할 때
X401을 지원합니다.
그만은 즉시 MPP도
솔직히 약간 돌려서 지원할 수가 있는데
이것처럼 AP2 안에서
X401을 약간 결제 레이어로 깔 수 있다
이렇게 생각하시면 됩니다.
아마 자세한 데는
이제 블록체인 기반에 해 주실 거니까
이쯤에서 넘어가겠습니다.
그래서 UCP나 이런 업데이트 팔로워하는 법은
여기서 이 내 크다라는 사이트에서
이제 쉽게 팔로워하실 수 있습니다.
이 정도 세트가 마치고
제가 에이전트 커버스에 대해서 좀
많이 생각하고 있는 거에 대해서
약간 간략하게 소개해 드리자는
팩터튼을 위해서면
당일성을 가져야 된다고 생각합니다.
흔히 이제 많은 에이전트 커버스
마이콜 페이먼트 804 평평 KY
등등에 이게 많은 게 왔거든요.
근데 저는 이게
저번에 있는 모나드 해컨템 때
진짜 봤었고 많이 봤었는데
결론적 당일성을 갖은 프로젝트가
수상할 수 있다 생각합니다.
일단 첫 번째로 아까
지연님께서 말씀해 주신 금융위에서
전략경제 프로그램에서
간단히 얘기한 거에서
스테이블 코인이 꼭 에이전트 페이먼트
이제 있을 필요가 없다.
이게 맞는 말이거든요.
그러니까 결론적으로
블록체인 기반 결제의 장점이 무엇일까
라고 생각을 해봐야 됩니다.
흔히 이야기하는
마이크로 페이먼트 이제
한 번에 결제할 수 있다는 것은
여기서 나왔다시피
이미 카드 네트워크에서는
그 뭐 100부를 채워두고
거기서 약간 좀 배치 정산 느낌을 해 가지고
한 번에 처리하는 방식을 통해 가지고
마이크로 페이먼트 처리할 수 있거든요.
그래서 그런 거 말고
진짜 블록체인 기반 결제가 필요한
이유를 생각해 봐야 돼요.
생각해 봤을 때
일단 인증 로거인 없이
진행 가능할 결제가 있겠고
그다음에 뭐 적은 수수료
빠른 속소가
결론적 카드 네트워크에 비해서
해자를 가질 수 있다고 생각합니다.
그래서 약간 이런 가점에서
약간 프로젝트를 빌딩하면 좋을 것 같고
두번째로 어느 시장을 노력하는 겁니다.
제가 저는 이제 크게 이제
에이전트 커머스 3가지
이제 타임 프레임을 나오는데
에이전트 투표를 해서
인간의 결제 안에 추천만 받는 구조나
아니면 에이전트에 위임을 하는 구조
아니면 혹은 에이전트에
모든 것을 이제 다 자유료용을 맡기시는 구조인데
이게 기존 커머스 시장에서
그러니까 우리가 흔히 이야기하는
뭐 청바지 사과나 이런 거 할 때
블록체인 결제가 장점이 있을까
새로운 커머스 시장에 도래하지 않을까
새로운 커머스 시장에서는
어떤 식으로 해제를 찾을 수 있을까
약간 이런 것처럼 당일성 시대입니다.
마지막은 어떤 레이어를 노릴 것인가 있는데
뭐 제가 없어 말씀드리는 레이언인데
여기서 제가 생각하기로는
해커톤에서 딱 에임 가진 걸 조그만한 게
커머스 체크하우치나 신은 의도증량
아니면 검증 카드 이 정도 레이어를 가지고
한번 좀 깊게 탐구해서
좋은 프로젝트를 내오면
충분히 좋은 결과를 가져올 수 있을 것 같습니다.
그리고 마지막으로
이제 결론적으로 GP 지키면 100점 100승이라고
현재 블록체인 기반의 에이전트 페이먼트
무엇을 타겟으로 하는 걸 보는 게 중요한데
흔히 나오는 XSAO 스캔타의 IO
NTP 스캔타의 IO
PAY.SH 등
조그만은 이제 사이트에서
어떤 엔드 포인트가 많이 팔렸나옵니다.
이 그래프는 이제 데이터 데시보드의
아르테미스에서 발표하는데
이제 초반기에는 토클런치라
페어민트가 중심이었던 결론적으로
현재는 데이터에서 서비스인 것 같다.
데이터를 제공하는 서비스 자체
그냥 휴니하게 너무 블록런기나
난센 이런 게 현재 주목받고 있거든요.
그래서 지금 형태를 보면서
어떤 식으로 접근하면 좋을 것 같다라고
생각하는 것도 좋을 것 같습니다.
그리고 이제 마지막으로 감을 잡기 위해서 유지케이스인데
첫 번째로 가장 좋은 거는
솔라나 콜레스엠 수상작을 참고하는 게 좋습니다.
그래서 이게 한 두 달 전에 나온
솔라나 글로벌 헨커톤의 수상작인데
이거를 쫙 보면
이제 AI 에이든트 관련된 프로젝트가
3이 정도 나옵니다.
이제 플로비아 402
이 팀은 저도 한번 인터뷰해 가지고
조만간 글을 써서 공유 드릴 것 같긴 한데
이 팀은 스트라이크 투 헨커톤에서 우승하고
프론티에스 수상하고
등등 이제 다양한 행보를 보여 하고 있는데
이런 식으로 헨커톤 수상작들이
어떤 와우 모먼트를 가져왔고
거기서 어떤 해제를 찾아야 되는지
한번 그 중심으로 찾아보면 좋을 것 같습니다.
그리고 두 번째로는
최근에 좀 핫했던
클라우드 플레이웨스
모네타레이션 Gateway인데
이게 어떤 느낌이냐면
뒤에서보면
사실 이게 X402의 당일성을 생각해야 되거든요.
저희가 홈페인스 드러와를 할 때
이게 수익 구조가 레터롤리라는
이제 그
그 field를 통해 가지고
결론적 기록이 돼요.
예를 들어서
제가 한 사이트에 들어가면 1 카운터가 되고
한 사이트 들어간 2 카운터는 이런 거잖아요.
근데 이제 사람이 들어가다가
이제 크롤링 도시 들어가고
그다음에 에이전트가 들어가면서
여러분이 예를 들어서
에이전트를 통해서
뭐 전국주합 찾아왔는데
그거 출처 직접 들어가지 않잖아요.
이런 것처럼
에이전트가 한 2만 3천 원 정도
이제 정보를 탐색하면
그중에서 딱 한 번만 인간이 들어가기 때문에
나머지 2만 3,950번에
이제 그것도 서버에 리소스만 남게 되고
서버는 실제로 이거 수익을 할 수가 없는 거죠.
근데 이것을 막기에는
에이전트나 이제 크롤러 자체가
결론적으로 이제
인터넷 주인이 될 거기 때문에
막는 것은 사실 시대 차호적이죠.
그렇기 때문에
결론적으로 에이전트에겐 적용 안 되기 때문에
에이전트를 위한 새로운 계산들을 만든 게
결론적 클라우드 플레이어의
모네타레이션 Gateway입니다.
그래서 결론적으로 에이전트가
리캐스트를 하면
이제 Gateway에서 X40인가 가격을 주고
그러면 그걸 보고
이제 에이전트가
이제 해당 뭐 결제 수단을 체크해서
이제 리샌드를 하면
그럼 이제 에이전트 원내에서
그럼 저 이 페이먼트를
해당 증거를 보여주고 난 다음에
뭐 이런 저 리스턴을 가져왔습니다.
뭐 이런 게 한 건데
이게 클라우드 플레이어가 약간 이런
좀 X40이 기반에 에이전트 프로
페이먼트 기반에 좀 상품 만들었다는 게
저는 생각보다 엄청
갑지 않을 생각이 들거든요.
그래서 뭔가 히커트로 하실 때도
약간 이런 빅테크나 이런
이런 회사가 어떤 식으로 적용했는지 고르면 좋을 것 같고
중간적으로 AWS도 약간 관련되서 상품이 있는데
이것도 한번 찾아보시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
그래서 이런 식으로 마무리 되고
당연히 저도 약간 이거에 대해서 쓴 글이 있으니까
한번 찾아보시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
그래서 이상으로 발표를 마치했고
뭐 뭐 분광하거나 이런 게 있었으면
뭐 텔레그램이나 디스코드를 통해서
질문 주시면 제가 성실이 답변드리겠습니다.
감사합니다.
네 오늘 이제 유진영 리서치님께서
이제 꼼꼼하게 답을 듣고
전체적인 시장에 대해서
이제 큰 그림이 그려져
그려지셨을 것 같습니다.
그러면 이제는 실제로 만들어볼 차례입니다.
저희가 정말 기중하게 모셨습니다.
구글 클라우드에 항소나 솔루션 아키펙트님이
네 하나의 아이디어가
네 디자인에서 출발해
프롬트 백앤드 구현 대화용 에이저트 주문 결제
클라우드 배포까지 이어지는
엔드 앤드 가정을
라이브 데모로 보여주실 예정인데요.
네 오늘의 패션 하이라이트라고 보시면 될 것 같습니다.
황선아 아키태크님께 마이크를 넘기게 했습니다.
좀 하우스
네 잘 들리실까요?
아 네
합니다.
저는 구글 클라우드에서
솔루션 아키태트로 일하고 있는 황선아라고 합니다.
어 되게 소개를
좀 부담스럽게 해주셔서
정말 꼭 도움이 되는 패션으로 전달을 드리고 싶은데요.
저는 오늘 구글 클라우드를 활용해서
바이브 코딩을 하는 방법에 대해서
이제 간단히 보여드리려고 합니다.
전 사실 웹스리나 이런 결제 시스템에 대해서는
사실 잘 알지는 못하고
제가 오늘 이 전 세션 드리면서도 굉장히 재미있게 들었는데
저는 초점을 맞출 거는
그 아이디어를 자연어를 통해서
구체화하고 실현하는 그 과정에 대해서
특히 구글 클라우드 제품들을 이용해서
어떻게 그걸 하실 수 있는지에 대한 과정을
보여드리려고 합니다.
어 바이브 코딩은 뭐 다들 너무나 잘 아실 것 같지만
바이브 코딩에 대해 잠깐 짓고 넘어가자면
이제 개발자 뿐만 아니라
다양한 사용자들이
프로그래밍 언어를 이해하고
코딩을 직접 하는 대신에
AI에게 자연어로 요구사항과 방향성을 제시해서
소프트웨어를 구축하는
새로운 개발 방식이라고 볼 수가 있겠습니다.
어 사실 개발자 분들은 잘 아시겠지만
몇 년 전까지만 해도 AI를 활용할 때는
내가 작성한 코드를 완성한다든지
그 다음에 오게 될 코드를 추천 받는다든지
하는 거에 머물렀었는데요.
그 이후에는 대화형으로 지원을 하면서
대화에 따라서 이제 코드를 업데이트하는
그 과정이 어 가능해졌습니다.
그리고 이제는 또 에이전트
에이전트 코드 코딩 시대인데요.
이제 큰 목표만 전달해주면
에이전트가 알아서
그 목표를 실행하기 위해서
필요한 도구를 사용하기도 하고
직접 개발을 하기도 해서
결과물 완성해내는 그 과정까지
이제는 지원을 하게 되었습니다.
그리고 앞서서도 MCP에 대해서
설명을 해주셨지만
이러한 에이전트 코딩 시대에서
또 이제 다양한 추를 사용할 수 있는
그 연동 역할라는 MCP가 또 중요해졌습니다.
AI의 내장된 능력만을 이용하는 게 아니라
외부 시스템과 연결할 수 있는 역할
하는 게 이 MCP이고요.
예를 들면 구글에서도
다양한 MCP 서버를 지원하고 있는데
구글의 빚데이터 시스템인
빅코리라고 하는 저희 서비스의 MCP랑
연결을 하게 되면
빅코리에 저장되어 있는 데이터가
어떤 데이터인지
스키마가 어떤 건지
이런 거를 파악을 해서
코드를 할 때
코딩을 할 때 활용을 할 수가 있게 됩니다.
그리고 스킬도 잘 정의해서 사용하시면
에이전트가 정확히
의도한 작업을 실행하는데
많은 도움이 됩니다.
이제 에이전트가 특정 작업을 하기 위한
작업 명세서를 미리 정리해 놓는다고
생각해 주시면 되는데요.
예를 들면 우리 회사의 보고서
작성하기 위한 스키를 정리한다고 하면
우리 회사에서 보고서를 작성할 때
사용하는 그런 포맥들
그다음에 톤들
그다음에 길이
이런 것에 대해서
자세하게 정의를 해놓으면
나중에 에이전트에게
우리 회사 보고서를 작성해줘라고 했을 때
이 스킬을 참고해서
정확히 원하는 우리 회사에 딱 맞는
그런 아웃풋이 나오게 됩니다.
저희가 사용하게 될 실습 도구는
첫 번째로 구글 스티치를 활용할 건데요.
스티치는 정확히 구글 클라우드의 제품은
아니고
모든 사용자들이 무료로 사용할 수 있는
디자인 추리입니다.
이 스티치는 자연으로
디자인을 해주는 추리라고
생각해 주시면 되는데요.
기존 그냥 재미나이나 다른
에이전트 추를 통해서도
디자인을 할 수 있지만
이 스티치는 디자인에
특히 특화되어 있는 도구이기 때문에
내가 정확히 만들고 싶은 디자인이 명확하고
그걸 좀 더 전문적으로 구현하고 싶은 경우에는
스티치를 사용하실 수가 있습니다.
그리고 다음으로는 엔티그래비티입니다.
엔티그래비티 2.0이
두 달 전에 출시가 되었고
구글 클라우드 환경에서도
사용할 수 있게 되었는데요.
엔티그래비티 2.0은
에이전트를 통해서
이제 내가 원하는
어플리케이션을 구축하기 위한
인터페이스를 제공하고
또 개발자 분들을 위해서는
터미널에서
엔티그래비티를 실행할 수 있는
CLI 기능도 제공하고 있습니다.
저는 오늘 보여드릴 때는
스티치 보여드리고
그다음 엔티그래비티 2.0으로
한번 보여드리도록 하겠습니다.
네, 이 엔티그래비티는
이제 에이전트로 코딩을 한다고
말씀을 드렸는데요.
당연하겠지만
구글 클라우드의 제품이기 때문에
재미나이를 지원하고 있습니다.
재미나이의 지금 가장 최신 모델은
3.5 플래시인데요.
3.5 플래시는 에이전트를
이제 위한 모델이라고 할 수 있을 정도로
이제 에이전트 향 작업에서
타고란 기능을 발휘하기 때문에
사용하실 때 3.5 플래시로 두고
사용을 해보시면 되겠습니다.
그리고 코 3.5 프로도 나올 예정입니다.
어, 엔티그래비티 2.0의 기능에 대해서
잠깐 먼저 설명드리면
어, 엔티그래비티 인터페이스를 들어가면
먼저 프로젝트를 만드실 수가 있습니다.
프로젝트는 내 특정 작업을 위한
격리된 환경이라고 생각을 해주시면 되는데요.
그래서 이제 그 특정 프로젝트별로
별도의 세팅을 해주실 수도 있고요.
그 프로젝트별로 대화를
실행하실 수가 있게 됩니다.
다음으로는 스케줄트 테스트입니다.
스케줄트 테스트는 내가 원하는 작업을
예약을 해놓으실 수가 있습니다.
일상적인 업무에 사용을 하실 수가 있는데요.
예를 들면
뭐 이제 매일 아침 9시마다
뭐 우리 회사, 우리 회사의
내 회사 이메일에서
내가 참고해야 되는 주요 이메일들을
브리핑 해준다든지 하는 용도로
사용하실 수가 있겠습니다.
다음으로는 슬래쉬 커맨드인데요.
슬래쉬 커맨드를 이제 잘 활용하시면
개발에 많은 도움을 받을 수가 있습니다.
예를 들면 골이라는 그 커맨드를 사용하시면
내가 에이전트에게 특정 목표를 제공해 주게 되고
그 목표를 달성할 때까지
에이전트가 실행이 됩니다.
다음으로 이제 제가 데모에서 보여드릴
그릴미라고 하는 이 슬래쉬 커맨드는
내가 에이전트에게 나 이런 작업을 하고 싶어 라고 하게 되면
이 그릴미 커맨드를 사용하시면
역으로 저에게 인터뷰를 하게 됩니다.
그 요구사항을 구체화할 수 있는
인터뷰를 하게 되어서
그 요구사항을 좀 더 구체화해서
내가 정확히 원하는 어플리케이션을 만들 수 있도록
도움을 주게 됩니다.
이외에도 다양한 슬래쉬 커맨드가 있기 때문에
슬래쉬 커맨드를 사용하셔서
이제 개발을 하고
검증을 한 데 많은 도움을 받으실 수가 있습니다.
바로 데모를 보여드리려고 하는데요.
데모를 시작하기 전에
데모의 흐름에 대해서 먼저 살펴보도록 하겠습니다.
데모의 흐름은 사실 데모 어플리케이션은
조금 단순하게 만들어봤는데요.
먼저 바이브 디자인이라고 하죠.
바이브 디자인은 스티치를 통해서
바이브 디자인을 해보도록 하겠고요.
그리고 엔티그래비티에서
스티치 MCP를 연동을 해서
내가 만든 디자인 SS을 가져오고
그다음 동적으로 서브 에젠트들을 가동해서
프런트엔드와 백엔드가
병렬로 실행되는 거를 확인하시게 됩니다.
그 다음 솔라나 생태계 기반에
페이다 셀 이제 그 연동을 해서
이제 코인으로 페이가 가능하게끔 하는
결제 시스템을 연동을 할 거고요.
그 다음에 이제 로컬에서 개발이 완료되면
클라우드 런이라고 하는 저희 구글 클라우드에
서버리스 인프라에
배포하는 과정까지 한 번 보시겠습니다.
저희가 시간 관계상 이제 이 모든 과정을
라이브로 보여드리기에는 조금 힘들어요.
그래서 이게 개발이 아무리 이제
에이전트로 빠르게 개발한다고 하더라도
10분에서 15분 그 이상이 걸릴 수도 있는
작업이기 때문에 일단 제가 간단한
데모 그 부분은 라이브로 보여드리고
그다음은 이제 제가 레코딩 해놓은 비디오
그리고 완료된 이제 SS을 보여드리는 과정으로
진행을 해보도록 하겠습니다.
저희가 사용하게 될 구글 클라우드에
서비스는 크게 세 가지인데요.
첫 번째로 파이어 스토어라고 하는
저희 서버리스 노에스쿨 데이터베이스입니다.
서버리스이기 때문에 일단 비용이 굉장히 저렴하고요.
그리고 스키마가 없고 내가 정의하는 대로
이제 필드를 추가할 수 있기 때문에
유연하게 사용을 하실 수가 있습니다.
그리고 두 번째로는 이제 저희 서버리스
배포할 수 있는 인프라인 클라우드 런을 사용할 거고요.
그 다음으로는 저희 클라우드 스토리지라고 하는
블록 스토리질을 사용하게 될
오젝트 스토리질을 사용하게 될 텐데
비정형 데이터를 저장하는 용도로
사용을 해보도록 하겠습니다.
그리고 페이다쉘에 대해서는
앞에서도 잠깐 언급을 드렸고
또 이 세션 다음에도 이제 진행을 할 거기 때문에
저는 특별히 뭐 이론적인 내용을 다루지는 않겠지만
이제 AI 에이전트에서 블록체인
이제 코인으로 결제할 수 있는 그 시스템 레이어로
이제 페이다쉘을 사용해서 연동을 해보도록 하겠습니다.
제가 지금 이제 그 솔라나 지갑까지
연동하는 것도 구현을 했고
실제로 페이가 가능한 상태인데
제가 테스트 넷을 받는 거를 이제 실패를 해서
이제 샌드박스 모드로 진행을 해보도록 하겠습니다.
제가 그 테스트 넷이라도 받으려고 했는데
그게 오비즈 때문인지 받기가 굉장히 힘들더라고요.
그래서 이제 페이다쉘에서 제공하는 샌드박스 모드로
결제가 어떤 흐름으로 이어지는지
위주로 한번 설명을 드리도록 하겠습니다.
네 그래서 데모를 보실 때 포인트는
엔티그래비티의 기능 중에 그리미를 통해서
어떻게 인터뷰를 통해서 이제 질문을 구체하는 과정에
대해서 한번 보시면 좋을 것 같고요.
그리고 단일 에이전트가 실행되는 게 아니라
필요에 따라서 여러 에이전트들이 병렬로 실행되는 과정도
한번 눈여겨봐 주시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
그리고 상품을 코인으로 결제하기 위해서
내 지갑과 연결하고 결제하는 과정도 한번 보실 거고요.
그리고 구글 클라우드에 어떤 제품들이 사용되고 있는지도
한번 확인해 보시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
네 바로 시작을 해 볼 텐데요.
네 일단 먼저 제가 저장해 놓은 데이터들에 대해서
보여드리도록 하겠습니다.
제가 구현하게 될 그 지금 바이브 코딩의 에세스는
테크 악세서리 쇼핑몰을 만들어 볼 거예요.
그래서 테크 악세서리 쇼핑몰을 만들기 위해서는
상품 정보가 있어야겠죠.
그래서 상품 정보들 지금 여기 파이어베이스 데이터베이스에
저장을 해 두었습니다.
보이시는 것처럼 이렇게 카테고리나 설명 그리고 기능들
그리고 이제 뭐 가격이라든지 현재 재고가 얼마나 있는지에 대한
정보를 넣어 놓은 상태라고 생각을 해 주시면 되고요.
여기 보이는 이미지 URL 같은 경우에는
저희 클라우드 스토리지의 비정형 데이터를 저장할 수 있는
클라우드 스토리지의 이미지를 이렇게 저장해 놓은 상태입니다.
이런 이미지들이 저장되어 있어서
이제 여기 보이시는 데이터베이스에서 정보를 가져올 때
이 이미지 URL도 참조해서 화면에 보여줄 수 있게끔
그렇게 구현을 했다고 생각을 해 주시면 좋을 것 같고요.
최종 이제 그 결과물을 보여드리면
이렇게 웹사이트가 만들어지게 되고
이제 제가 저장한 데이터에서 이 이미지까지 보이는 걸 확인하실 수가 있고요.
이미지가 보이게 되고 또 내 지갑과 연동할 수 있게 됩니다.
지금 제가 연동을 해놨지만
디스커넥트를 하고 나서 다시 셀렉트 월래스 하게 되면
내 지갑 솔라나 지갑과 연동을 할 수 있게 되고요.
제가 이미 연동을 해놨기 때문에 이렇게 바로 연동이 되는 것처럼 보이지만
실제로는 내 지갑에서 이렇게 연결을 할 수 있는
이런 기능이 사실 제일 처음 연결한 단계에서는
추가가 되게 됩니다.
그리고 AI 에이전트를 통해서
이제 내가 원하는 결제를 할 수 있게끔 하는 기능까지
이 결과물로 나오게 된다라고 이해해 주시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
그럼 첫 번째 과정으로 스티치를 한번 확인해 보도록 하겠습니다.
저희 구글 스티치에 검색하시면
스티치 웹사이트로 바로 들어가실 수가 있게 되고요.
스티치 웹사이트 처음 들어가게 되면
이렇게 자연으로 입력할 수 있는 화면이 나타나게 됩니다.
그럼 여기서 앱을 디자인할 건지
웹을 디자인할지 선택하실 수가 있고
사용하게 될 모델도 선택을 해 주실 수가 있습니다.
그럼 여기서 이제 내가 원하는 디자인에 대한 요구사항을 제출할 수 있게 되고요.
저는 이렇게
이렇게 한번 요청을 해보도록 하겠습니다.
제가 뭘 제출했는지 아마 잘 안 보이셨을 텐데
지금 이렇게 돌아가는 동안 한번 확인을 해보시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
제가 모던한 테크 가젯 이커머스 웹사이트를 디자인해달라고 요청을 했고요.
혹시 화면이 너무 작나요? 제가 조금 추가해 볼게요.
이렇게 보이시면
제가 모던한 테크 가젯 이커머스 웹사이트 메인 페이지를 디자인해달라고 요청하면서
제가 필요한 기능들이나 보여줘야 되는 화면에 대해서 요청을 해봤습니다.
그러면 이제 에이전트가
이제 이 스티치 안에 내장되어 있는 에이전트가 작업을 시작하게 되고요.
제일 처음 하게 되는 거는 이제 기본적인 컴포넌트 디자인을 하게 됐고
그 다음에 이제 이 웹사이트의 메인 화면을 실제로 디자인을 하게 됩니다.
이 스티치는 제가 이제 고객분들한테 보여드리기도 좋아하는 게
이렇게 실시간으로 디자인이 진행되는 걸 확인을 하실 수가 있기 때문에
좀 많은 분들이 흥미로워하면서 보시는 것 같아요.
그래서 이 스티치를 통해서 디자인을 하실 수가 있게 됩니다.
이렇게 스티치를 통해 디자인을 메인 페이지를 디자인하게 되면
이걸 바탕으로 수정을 요청하기도 하고
상세 페이지, 주문 페이지, 결제 페이지를 추가적으로 요청을 하실 수도 있게 됩니다.
이렇게 만들어진 디자인 에셋 같은 경우에는
저희 이렇게 선택을 한 다음에
이제 지원하는 외부 시스템으로 이렇게 익스포트를 하실 수도 있고요.
집 파일로 로컬로 다운로드를 받으실 수도 있습니다.
저희는 지금 엔티 그래비티에서 MCP로 연결을 할 거기 때문에
MCP로 연결할 때는 이 스티치, 내 계정의 스티치에서 사용하는 API 키가 필요하거든요.
그래서 API 키를 발급받는 방법은 내 계정 이 아이콘을 클릭하시게 되면
스티치 세팅으로 들어가게 됩니다.
이 스티치 세팅에 들어가게 되면 이 API 키를 생성할 수 있는 이 아이콘이 나오게 되고요.
이걸 선택하시면 API 키가 발급됩니다.
이 API 키를 MCP 서버를 등록할 때 사용을 하실 수가 있습니다.
여기까지 스티치를 통한 디자인을 해보셨고요.
제가 시간관계상 그 많은 기능을 보여드리지는 못했는데
여기서 보시면 이렇게 스티치 디자인이 완료되면
제한하는 프롬프트를 통해서 추가적인 요청을 하실 수도 있고요.
아니면 이렇게 하나만 만들어주는 게 아니라
기본적으로 3개의 디자인을 만들어줘 이런 식으로
요청을 하실 수도 있습니다.
이런 식으로 디자인을 구체화 했다라고 가정을 하고
이제 다음 스텝을 한번 진행해 보도록 하겠습니다.
네, 구글 안티그래비티는 저희가 기본 개인계정으로 접속을 하실 수도 있고요.
구글 클라우드 프로젝트를 통해서 접속을 하실 수도 있습니다.
저는 구글 클라우드 프로젝트를 통해서 접속하는 방법
그러니까 엔터프라이즈 사용자를 위한 접속 방법으로
한번 로그인을 해 보도록 하겠습니다.
이렇게 구글 클라우드 프로젝트를 사용하겠다라고 선택을 하게 되면
이렇게 이제 제 구글 클라우드 계정으로 로그인을 하게 됩니다.
네, 저는 이미 로그인이 완료된 상태이기 때문에
연동까지 됐고 이렇게 들어가게 되면
제가 사용하는 구글 클라우드 계정 중에서도
제가 사용하는 프로젝트를 지정을 해줘야 합니다.
저는 제가 사용하는 프로젝트를 이렇게 지정을 해줬습니다.
그러면 이제 이 프로젝트에 있는 이제 제 프로젝트에 있는 이제 권한
권한이라든가 그 다음에 빌린 그러니까 결제가 되는
저희 사용한 리소스가 결제되는 시스템으로 이제 진행이 되게 되는 거고요.
처음 들어가게 되면 왼쪽에 이렇게 프로젝트 목록이 쭉 나오게 되고
내가 원하는 프로젝트를 이렇게 생성하실 수도 있습니다.
그리고 제 밑에 세팅을 보시면 이건 글로벌 세팅 그러니까 이 엔티그래비티
어플리케이션 전체에 적용되는 글로벌 세팅이 있다고 보시면 되는데
확인해보실만한 거는 이제 이 시퀴리티 관련된 설정이라고 해서
이제 사용 어떤 작업을 할 때마다 사용자의 승인을 반드시 받을 건지
아니면 에이전트가 알아서 하도록 줄지 뭐 이런 것들을 선택하실 수가 있습니다.
저는 이번에는 빠른 데모를 위해서 이제 모든 세이브티 배리어를 이제
없애는 터보 모드로 할 건데요.
여러분들께서는 본인의 그런 생각에 맞게 설정하시면 되겠습니다.
제일 처음 프로젝트를 선택할 때는 퀵스타트를 누르게 되면
이제 랜덤한 이름의 폴더가 만들어지면서 랜덤한 이름의 프로젝트가 실행되게 됩니다.
그리고 대화를 할 때는 이 프로젝트 아래의 대화가 생성되는 그런 흐름이라고 생각을 해주시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
그리고 이걸 실행하기 전에 MCP 설정을 다시 한 번 보여드리면
이 세팅에서 커스테마이제이션으로 가시면 이제 스킬이랑 MCP를 확인하실 수가 있습니다.
저는 지금 스티치 MCP가 연결되어 있는 상태인데요.
연결하고 싶으신 경우에는 이 ad MCP를 선택하셔서 스티치를 검색하시고
api 키를 연결해주시면 되겠습니다.
그러면 저희가 만든 스티치에 있는 프로젝트 에세스를 가져와서
디자인을 정의하는 과정을 한 번 해보도록 하겠습니다.
제가 요청을 한 번 해봤는데요.
스티치의 솔라나 테크 가재 스토어 프로젝트의 디자인 자산을 참고해서
디자인.md의 생성에 달라라고 요청을 해보았습니다.
이제 이렇게 되면 스티치에서 가져오라고 했기 때문에
스티치 MCP 툴을 바로 호출하는 걸 확인하실 수가 있고요.
스티치 MCP 툴에 있는 여러 가지 툴 중에
프로젝트를 리스트업하는 그런 툴을 호출하는 걸 보실 수가 있습니다.
이렇게 호출하게 되면 내가 이 테크 가재 스토어라고 하는 프로젝트를 검색하게 되고
이 프로젝트의 디자인 자산들을 확인을 해서
이제 그걸 디자인.md 파일에 작성을 하게 됩니다.
이 과정을 잠깐 기다려보도록 할게요.
기다리는 동안 한 가지 기능을 더 보여드리면
아까는 저희가 전역 설정으로 왼쪽 하단에 있는 세팅을 선택을 했지만
내 프로젝트에서만 해당하도록 설정을 해주실 수도 있습니다.
이렇게 프로젝트 세팅을 설정을 하시면
이제 이거는 글로벌 설정을 따라가지 않고 내가 원하는 대로
이 프로젝트에서만 사용할 수 있게 커스테마이징을 할 수가 있게 되는 거고요.
여기서 MCP 툴 중에 지금 보시면
스티치에서 사용 가능한 툴들이 여기서도 확인하실 수가 있습니다.
스티치에 다양한 툴 기능들을 활용할 수 있는 걸 봐주시면 좋을 것 같고요.
지금 진행되고 있는 과정은
보시면 리스트 프로젝트를 해서 프로젝트 리스트를 가져오고
거기에 있는 이제 스크린들, 이제 디자인 자산들을
다운로드하는 걸 확인하실 수가 있습니다.
잘 안 보이시네요 잠시만요.
지금은 잘 보이시나요 혹시?
이게 가끔 이제 제가 보여주는 라이브 화면이 약간 먹동이 될 때가 있는데
지금 진행되고 있는 과정은
스티치의 MCP 툴을 활용해서 디자인 자산을 가져오는 과정들을 해보고 있고요.
이 과정이 완료되는 거 한번 기다려보도록 하겠습니다.
지금 디자인.md를 작성하는 과정이 시작된 걸로 보이고요.
지금 이렇게 디자인.md가 작성된 거를 여기서 보실 수가 있습니다.
지금은 제가 별도로 요청을 안 했기 때문에 영어로 정의가 되어 있는데
이것도 한글로 정의하도록 요청을 하셔도 됩니다.
이렇게 주변 디자인 자산이 요약된 걸 확인하실 수가 있고요.
이렇게 디자인까지 완료된 다음에
이제 본격적으로 어플리케이션 빌드하는 과정을 보신다면
이렇게 지금 저는 그릴미를 활용을 해서
인터뷰, 저를 인터뷰하도록 한번 해보도록 하겠습니다.
지금 잘 보이십니다.
지금 보시면 디자인.md를 활용해서 프론트 앤들을 디자인하고
그 다음 파이어 스토어에 저장된 실제 제품 데이터를 결합한
쇼핑몰을 빌드하고 싶다.
그리고 내가 구글 클라우드 이 파이어 스토어에 해당하는
그 프로젝트도 명시하고
이제 이렇게 만들고 싶다라고 한번 에이전트에게 말을 해보겠습니다.
그럼 에이전트는 제 요구상을 이제 이해를 한 다음에
그 비어있는 내용, 이제 구체화해야 되는 내용에 대해서 질문을 하게 됩니다.
예를 들면 서버칙 실행 환경이 필수적인데
직접 호출하는 거는 위험하다 어떻게 할까요 라고 했을 때
그러니까 클라이언트에서 호출하는 대신 서버에서 호출해도 될지
이런 것들을 추천하고 있는데요.
저는 이번 서버 사이즈의 아키텍처로 한번 서브미스를 해보도록 하겠습니다.
한 개만 더 보여드릴게요.
그 다음에는 이제 스키 마음이 개발 단계에서
볼백 지원 정책은 어떻게 하고 싶은 것인가요?
이거 같은 경우에는 프로덕트라는 컬렉션에
아무 데이터도 없을 때 어떻게 조치할 건지에 대해서 물어보고 있는데요.
이거는 자동으로 시딩할 수 있게끔 하는 기능을 지원하겠다
이런 것들을 이제 선택해 주실 수 있고